>> STEVENS: We'd like to welcome our author
today, Jean Hanff Korelitz who will be reading
from her new book, "Admission." Jean was raised
in New York City, and graduated from Dartmouth
College and Clare College in Cambridge. She's
the author of several novels, the most recent
of which are "The White Rose" and "Admission"
which just came out. She's also published
a children's novel and a book of poems. She's
also contributed many articles and essays
to magazines. And she lives in Princeton with
her family, the Poet and Professor Paul Muldoon
and their children, and she works full time
as a writer and part-time as a chauffeur,
i.e., mom. So I'd like to welcome Jean and
thank you very much.
>> KORELITZ: Thank you, Molly. Thank you to
this small but quality audience. This is actually
the first invitation that I had months ago
before the book came out. And I was very thrilled
to be invited, and I'm very, very, very happy
to be here. As Molly said, "Admission" is
my fourth novel. The subject matter is something
I've been thinking about since my own horrendous
experience of applying to colleges back in
the 1970s. You know, what was a gruesome process
back then has only grown more gruesome and
horrendous, as those of you who have applied
to college in the last 20 years can doubtless
testify. I became very interested in the place
in our society that Ivy League applications
has come to occupy, especially in our sort
of family tree of American obsessions with
things like social standing, social class,
money, immigration, ideas of success, and...
It just seemed to me that every time I open
one of these subjects to look at them, I found
myself looking at Ivy League admissions. I
don't know how that happened, and luckily
I don't really have to answer that question
in my novel. You know, there are other books
that really have looked very directly at that
question, and I've read most of them. But
I'm a novelist, and I'm interested in how
people respond to pressures in their lives.
And the protagonist of Admission is an admissions
officer at Princeton. I worked at Princeton
for two years as what they call an "outside
reader" in the admissions office. I was not,
thank goodness, given the terrible responsibility
of making decisions about who got in. But
I was--I did read many hundreds of applications
and evaluated them as I have been trained
to do. It was a fascinating experience; it
was a humbling experience; it was an experience
that made me feel really good about who's
applying to college right now. And that in
itself is interesting, because I have a teenage
daughter. You know, I think her generation
has been kind of maligned a little bit. You
know, all we hear about is the texting and
the Facebook-ing, and we don't really hear
about what they're going through and what
they have on their minds. And if you want
to know what's on the minds of American 17-year-olds,
that's where you find it, in their college
application essays. They were profoundly moving.
They were extraordinarily insightful and sensitive
and just wonderful to read. My feelings about
how the system currently works are complicated,
but at least in terms of the college where
I worked, at Princeton, they're pretty positive.
I really came away feeling that the system
may not be perfect but I couldn't think of
a better system. And people out there who
have lots of ideas about how it should be
done, I don't think they've really thought
very carefully about it either. Because some
of the college environments that they would
create with their methodology; for example,
setting, you know, setting your computer to
pick the top scoring applicants and then walk
away, would not really produce very interesting
college environments, certainly, not the kind
of environment we see at Princeton, for example.
So I don't have an axe to grind with how it's
done. I think it's complicated, but I think
that's what makes it interesting. So I'm going
to read two excerpts from the novel. My protagonist
is a 38-year-old woman named Portia Nathan.
She's very complicated. She's not very happy.
She's made some decisions in her life that
have never really left her and now they're
really coming into the foreground of her life;
hence, the double meaning of the word "admission."
And at the start of this excerpt that I'm
going to read, Portia has just returned home
to Princeton after a difficult Christmas visit
with her mother in Vermont. She's come home
to an empty house because while she's been
away, her partner of 16 years has moved out
to move in with someone else who's already
pregnant, so it's a rough homecoming. And
after a very short time back in her house,
she discovers that she's pretty unhappy to
be home. So this is where we're going to start
the excerpt. And you'll see why I chose this
excerpt because a certain internet company
is in fact mentioned in this excerpt, so feel
free to cheer. Standing in the dull silence
of her foyer, Portia understood that she had
no clear idea of what to do with herself,
except to get away from this place. Methodically,
she considered and rejected other places to
be, including the gym, the supermarket at
the end of her street, any public space downtown.
At any of these, Mark and Helen might be lurking,
ready to display their happiness and gestational
glow. With each locale indeed came a jolt
of distress like a shot of black ink to the
system, feathering out to each extremity before
fading. It was the return of pain, its forces
rested and restored during her short distraction,
and ready with a reconsidered battle plan.
Considering her new circumstances, there seemed
to be only one place she could retreat to.
And realizing this, Portia duly began her
retreat, locking the front door behind her
and picking her way over the hard snow back
to the car. She had been home less than half
an hour. She had been able to stand being
home for only half an hour. She had the sense
suddenly of running before a wave. Moments
later, she was cruising downtown for a parking
spot. The town was wide open and she pulled
in opposite Nassau Hall, telling herself that
it really was a rational, laudable thing to
go to work late in the afternoon on a day
when the rest of the campus was still in steely
silence. This time of year after all was not
a vacation for her. The application deadline
had only just come and gone, and so had commenced
reading season, a tunnel of stress and weighty
decisions, ringing phones; an email inbox
that filled at the rate of four messages per
minute; students terrified they had mistyped
their Social Security numbers; guidance counselors
duty-bound to report that an applicant along
with the rest of the football team had just
been given a citation for disorderly conduct.
And always, always parents. Parents. Susanna
had been entirely uninvolved in Portia's own
college search. She remembered one heated
discussion about applying to Smith: reactionary
playground for future Republican wives or
hotbed of radical lesbianism. But apart from
that it had more or less been her own show.
Had Susanna read her essays, checked for spelling
errors; had she offered to hunt down friends
or cousins with connections to the various
admissions offices--misguided though that
surely would been even back then. Had she,
God forbid, herself called up the offices
demanding to speak to whoever was in charge
about the brilliance and promise of her daughter.
Compared with the parents Portia was dealing
with now, Susanna looked like a saint. Portia
hauled her bags of folders through the FitzRandolph
Gate. Nassau Hall, Princeton University's
nerve center--and for a few heady months in
1777, home to the infant US government--looked
majestic in the failing light with its great
preening tigers and fluttering ivy. And behind
it, the campus unfurled, stalwart buildings
linked by deserted walkways. Looking up at
West College, she saw no lights at all, not
Clarence's corner office, [INDISTINCT] partner
were in New Haven with friends; not Dylan's,
visiting his parents at Houston; not Corrine's,
with the kids on some island. That she was
here after nightfall was not in itself unusual.
In January, February, and March, as the intense
period of reading gave way to the still more
intense reading period of committee meetings,
all of them frequently worked late into the
night, percolating along in a fittingly collegial
rhythm. She had sometimes certainly been the
last one out of the door, intent on making
it to Western Oregon or the Archbishop Mitty
School, or the imperious baseball coach's
most urgent request before allowing herself
to head for home. But coming in like this,
alone in the darkness to an empty building--in
all these years it was a first. The unbroken
line of dark windows was definitely disconcerting,
but at the same time she felt some relief.
There would be no one out there to question
her. She opened the door with her own key
and went first to the administrative warren
at the back of the building, passing the abandoned
receptionist's desk. She turned on the lights
as she went, bathing the nondescript corridor
in harsh fluorescent illumination that picked
up every ding and mark on the walls, passing
the silent photocopier in its alcove. Against
one wall, two of the fax machines were lit
and humming, neatly depositing pages and pages
into their trays. In the cubicles screensavers
pulsed and danced, the smorgasbord of ill-judged
baked goods had been cleared away; only a
spattering of crumbs left behind. On Martha's
desk, a phone purred forlornly, five times,
six times, then went silent. It was all in
fact very silent. She hoisted her bags onto
the counter below the staff mailboxes and
began to lift out handfuls of files. There
were a few she'd flagged to remove at this
point, and she went hunting for them now,
quickly locating the fluorescent pink post-it
notes on their covers. These were folder she
had questions about for one reason or another
small items she might already have dealt with
if Susana were not such a Luddite who refused
to own a computer. Because she was however
and because she did not; because Portia had
to climb to drive into Hanover to undertake
this sensitive business on some public terminal,
she had merely flagged the files to come back
to. One of these was a boy from a private
day school near Boston whose guidance counselor,
a woman Portia had met when she visited the
school last spring, had declined to answer
two notable questions on the school secondary
report: Has the applicant ever been found
responsible for a disciplinary violation at
your school, whether related to academic misconduct
or behavioral misconduct that resulted in
the applicant's probation, suspension, removal,
dismissal, or expulsion? Has the applicant
ever been convicted of a misdemeanor, felony,
or other crime? Almost always, the answer
to these questions was no. Sometimes it was
yes. And sometimes that was not in itself
the kiss of death. There were kids who'd made
mistakes and grown from them. There were excessive--there
were victims of excessive zero tolerance school
rules: suspended for carrying a loaded water
pistol or pointing a finger and declaring
"bang." There was even the occasional Jean
Valjean crime of necessity. She had never
forgotten a boy from Oregon which shoplifted
liver for his family. Liver. If only he had
been a stronger student. But she could not
remember a single instance in which the guidance
counselor had declined to answer these questions.
It could, of course, be an oversight, a typo.
But at this school, with tuition upward of
$25 grand a year and a student parking lot
crowded with Lexus 2Ks and BMWs, Portia suspected
not. Another worrying application was from
a Rhode Island girl whose complex, mellifluous
essay was somewhat at odds with her low English
grades and poor score on the writing section
of the SAT, not to mention the fact, the favorite
book listed in the few detail section was
Pride and Privilege by Jane Austin. That's
A-U-S-T-I-N. Portia, accordingly, wanted to
check the girl's tribute to Fannie Lou Hamer
against their databank of essays for sale.
These were gleaned mainly from internet sources
where they were billed as teaching tools and
slaughtered with disclaimers, but supplemented
by an Iowa entrepreneur with an essayist-for-hire
business. This unpleasant individual had decided
to publish his expertise in book form, and
closed up shop by mailing his entire backlist
of custom essays to every college his clients
had ever attended, plus People Magazine. Of
course, the Rhode Island girl might simply
have reason to the challenge of her essay:
taking her time, thinking through her points,
checking her sentences carefully to avoid
grammatical errors. But there was something
in the ease of the language that worried Portia.
Correctness after all was achievable with
sweat. But in her experience, it was nearly
impossible to build grace into prose. There
was also a boy from Boston Latin who had furnished
the list of Princeton philosophers he wanted
to work with and an essay with such dense
philosophical prose that Portia had had no
idea what he was talking about. In fact, she
could have sworn when she'd read it that Susana's
kitchen table days earlier that it had something
to do with zombies. What's next? She thought,
Mummies and Vampires? She had decided to send
the essay to David and asked him to sort it
out. Philosophers seemed to have a knock for
recognizing their own kind, as well as the
impostors in their midst. Finally, there was
the Connecticut boy whose long list of school
of government offices, dramatic roles, community
service projects, and baseball positions had
ended with the words "National Judo Champion."
It might, of course, be true. But in Portia's
previous dealings with bonafide National Judo
champions, and not a few had indeed applied
to Princeton, this accomplishment did tend
to be noted in recommendations, and to require
enough practice time to preclude student government,
drama, and varsity baseball. National Judo
champions also had a tendency to write about
being National Judo champions. They solicited
their coaches for references and supplied
newspaper reports, attesting to the fact that
they were, well, National Judo champions.
It would easily be settled by Google, Portia
thought, finding the file at the very bottom
of the stack and sitting it aside. Why anyone
would bother to lie in the age of Google was
baffling. "We are trusting skeptics," her
first Dean of Admissions had told her years
before. "We believe what they tell us, but
they'd better be telling us the truth." This
was Harold McKendry, the soon-to-be-former
Dean of Admissions at Dartmouth who had hauled
her aboard the profession in the spring of
his final Dartmouth year. Harold's sense of
fair play, the fair play he sweetly assumed
to everyone else likewise embraced, had been
one of his most endearing qualities. Yet the
horror of the so-called new rules of admissions,
the outsmarting and end-runs and decoding
now rampant out there; the snake oil salesman
promising to package and sell your kids to
his or her school of choice. For as long as
he could, and longer perhaps than he should
have, Harold stubbornly regarded each application
as an open invigorating conversation between
his staff and the applicant in which there
could be no dissembling on either side. He
expected total candor from each applicant
and maintained that expectation even after
little wildfires of scandal broke through
the industry in the 1990s: kids getting other
kids to take their SATs for them; applicants
who wrote their own recommendations; people
pretending to be Rothchilds and ranch hands.
These events had been personally wounding
to Harold, but he had stayed the course, doing
his best to ride the new wave, trying to maintain
his personal honor code. There was something
a little haunting about this terribly ordinary
room, Portia decided. She tried for a moment
to see it not as the generic office it absolutely
was--but as the epicenter of so much urban
speculation by students, teachers, counselors,
and the parents. To them, this utilitarian
space was the holding pen where their child
and all of his or her antagonists were gathered,
vetted, directed, shunted into narrower and
narrower corridors, leading to smaller and
smaller vestibules, where they were commanded
to wait in mute distress face-to-face with
their most closely matched fellow aspirants.
Wrestlers here, legacies there, Pakistanis
to the right, woodwinds, novelists, witheringly
brilliant mathematicians, faculty kids, staff
kids, movie star kids, movies stars, ordinary
decent kids, good debaters, great debaters,
boys who wanted to be Brian Green, girls who
wanted to Steven Sondheim or Meg Whitman or
Quentin Tarantino. There was, for instance,
one tiny chamber in which the diver from Wisconsin
sat knee to bandaged knee with the diver from
Maine; the lounge where the girls from MIT's
Women's Technology Program were briefly, uncomfortably
reunited; the claustrophobic cubicle where
the classically trained soprano from Florida
eyed the classically trained soprano from
Los Angeles, and the classically trained soprano
from Cleveland. That it didn't actually work
like this was not even relevant, because Portia
understood the symbolic power of this place,
banal as it was. That power was even greater,
she suspected, than the symbolic power of
their individual offices upstairs. She had
been inside machine for so long that she sometimes
forgot how this applying-to-college thing
had looked from the outside. But it did come
back, vividly back, when she tried to remember.
It had been like watching a mass of seemingly
identical sheep cram themselves into a great
black building with no windows knocking against
one another, stepping on one another's hooves
and over their panicked bodies when they fell.
At the other end of the building, only a thin
line of sheep trickled out into bountiful
fields. And what was it about those sheaths
which look, to all intents and purposes, exactly
like every sheath that were crowded in. What
made them special? Why should they get the
meadow when those others were barred? What
happens inside that box was a mystery, a secret
shielded from the light. She remembered how
the class ahead of her in high school had
been sorted with the most cerebral Latin geek
shout out from every college she applied to,
while the class's drug dealer of choice has
his pick in Harvard and Brown. How the valedictorian
who was also the student body president retreated
in humiliation to a safety school, while the
dullest dishwater football player charted
off to Cornell. Who were these people in the
admissions office at Swarthmore and Williams?
And what could they have been thinking when
they accepted Camilla Walden, Portia's soccer
teammate and the most superficial girl she
had ever met, but passed over Gordana Miles
who wrote her own column in the school newspaper,
and had actually published three short articles
in 17 Magazine. There was perhaps no mystery,
however, as baffling as that of her own admission
to Dartmouth. She had been a worried high
school senior lacking in, well, anything special,
really. A pretty good student, a pretty good
soccer player, a pretty good writer, and all-around
nice person, Portia knew exactly what would
happen to her own college application if it
arrived through some warp of time and space
in this room today. With her strong GPA and
merely quite good scores, busy athletics schedule
and character building volunteer efforts,
Portia Nathan's application would have landed
in the great moving tide of similar applications.
Great kids, smart kids, hardworking kids who
would certainly do great at whatever college
they ended up going to, which almost certainly
wasn't going to be Princeton. The secret of
her own mediocrity was quite likely similarly
held by men and women all over the industry.
To wade through these best and brightest 17-year-olds
was to be at once deeply reassured by the
goodness and potential of the American near-adult
population--and deeply humbled by one's own
relative shortcomings. These students were
absolutely going to make scientific discoveries,
solve human problems, produce important works
of art and scholarship. And generally, as
so many of them pointed out, give back to
their communities and make the world a better
place. She, on the other hand, was fit only
to make life-altering decisions on their behalf.
And how could that make sense? So that's the
end of the first excerpt. Are there any burning
questions or should I segue directly? Or you
can hold them until later.
>> STEVENS: Comment? Okay.
>> FEMALE: I have a question, actually.
>> KORELITZ: Okay.
>> FEMALE: You said that you were kind of
intrigued by the admissions process for a
long time since you applied. What made you
go ahead and take that step to approach the
Dean of Admissions and ask to be a reader
and, with the intention of eventually writing
the book?
>> KORELITZ: Yeah. I knew that Princeton--I'm
a faculty spouse at Princeton so I've watched
an entire generation of Princeton students
pass through my husband's classes and my own
home, because I have kids and Princeton students
are fabulous babysitters. So, I really have
had my eye on Princeton students for a long
time, and I love them. I adore them. I think
they are amazing people, but they're terribly
ordinary, too. And you know, when you look
at other college students, you know, it's
not that they have light shining out of them
that makes them those sheep that are the ones
that get the meadow. And of course, I was
fascinated. I've heard--you know, lot of people
talk about how hard these decisions were,
how most of the applicants to these colleges
are perfectly capable of coming in and doing
the work and contributing to the community.
My question is the same as almost everybody
else's. How on earth can you decide? And you
know that it's only getting harder, because
in defiance of all, you know, logic in the
last couple of years with the economy tanking,
you know, applications to places like Princeton
have gone up. And not just a little, a lot.
So, you know, whereas in my day 30 years ago,
you know, I think the acceptance rate at my
college was something like 18%. That seemed
pretty tough to me. Today, my college is below
10%. So I mean I'm full of compassion for
our kids, basically, who are going through
this now. So I went to them and I said, "You
know, I want to write about this. I want to
write a novel about Ivy League admissions.
Will you hire me?" And frankly, I didn't expect
them to say yes, but they did. And as I said
before, you know, I really love the work.
It was such a fascinating job. And I learned
both those things that, you know, the ones
who get in are absolutely spectacular but
they're very ordinary, too. So, you know,
there is no, you know, be all and end all
that makes that difference, and yet you can
see the ones that really, really shine among
the brilliant and amazing. So, you know, I
have a kid; I have a daughter who is about
to go through this, so I really feel everybody's
pain. So, anyway, let me move on to the next.
This is actually from the following chapter,
and I know you want to find out what happened
to all of those kids who Portia flagged. So,
now you're going to find out what happens
to them. And you know, there's quite a bit
of humor in this book. Just because this is
incredibly serious to a lot of people including
me, it doesn't mean it's not incredibly funny,
too. The kid, who had written about zombies,
it turned out, was the real thing. His impenetrable
essay which she had dispatched to David through
the university mail came winging back the
first week in January with a cover note that
read "Definitely. Absolutely." Portia found
the file in the overhead shelf she used as
a parking lot for applications awaiting something
or other. She slipped this memo in the back
and made a note in the department rating area
at the reader's card, a seldom used but highly
influential section on the front. Then before
she let it go, and armed with David's endorsement,
she made another attempt to glean some sense
from the essay. Here's the essay. "Certain
things are conscious. We may not know what
it's like to be a dog or a bat, but we know
or at least we think we know that animals
have feelings and experiences. We also know
that a creature's conscious life is somehow
determined by what's going on in its brain.
So here's the question. What exactly is the
relation between conscious experience and
the brain activity that underlies it? Many
philosophers, materialists have thought that
conscious experience just is brain activity
in the same sense in which heat is just the
motion of molecules. The zombie thought experiment
puts pressure on this sort of view. We seem
to be able to imagine or conceive a creature
that is just like you in every physical respect
down to the last detail, but which is altogether
unconscious. A zombie will move and talk as
if it were awake and genuinely aware of its
surroundings but its inner light is off. It
has no subjective experience. Now the fact
that we can imagine such creatures gives us
some reason to believe that they are logically
possible. But if it's logically possible for
a creature to have a brain just like yours
and no conscious experience, then consciousness
is not literally identical to brain activity.
Instead, we should say that brain activity
normally causes consciousness in the sense
in which heating up the filament in a light
bulb normally causes it to glow. On this view,
the physical aspects of an organism are distinct
from its subjective mental aspects. At best,
they are various causal laws connected the
two domains." She read this twice, but could
not follow the logic past the point about
the inner light being off. Did this in fact
indicate that her own inner light was off?
Nonetheless, she wrote her summary and checked
"high priority admit" at the bottom of the
card, then put the file in the pile of folders
to go to Corrine for second reading. Her colleagues
were on the early stages of their shared annual
affliction. The traveling was done for the
year, and what remained was this confluence
of the cold on winter. And the all-in-our-hands
sense of bleak responsibility, to the trustees
and faculty, of course, and to the guidance
counselors who are, for better or worse, they're
partners in the work of getting the right
students into the freshman class. And yes,
to the alumni, because Princeton honored its
graduates and wished to attain their high
opinion. But mainly to the applicants themselves,
who collectively seemed to hover everywhere
in Portia's imagination by spectral Jude the
Obscures waiting for the verdict on their
futures. And Portia very much feared, their
sense of self-worth. Sometimes she imagine
them waif like across Cannon Green behind
West College and along Nassau Street winding
their white supplicating hands through the
great iron gates. This was not needless to
say an image she shared with her colleagues.
No one was complaining aloud, but then again
no one had to. The weight of the burden was
intense and everywhere, and the entire crew,
fighting the same cold, shuffled through the
corridors with the same set of dour thoughts.
Portia too was well into her winter sinus
misery, a malady that typically began after
New Year's, did battle with the tag team of
antibiotics over the winter months, and finally
surrendered to modern medicine just in time
for the pollen surge in April. It had begun
right on schedule the week she returned from
Vermont, flickering behind her cheekbones
as the year turned, sneaking tendrils of pain
along the facial nerves, coiling around her
ears and scalp. At her appointment with the
internist, she got a prescription for Septin,
the best of a bad lot, and asked for Ambien
which she had been given but was not yet brave
enough to use. Instead, she lay in bed timing
the pounding in her head against the dull
clicking of the bedside clock, feeling the
pain across her entire face as if the bones
of her skull were contracting steadily, the
flesh struggling against containment. This
was not an effective sleep aid. The house
would not seem to warm up, and she wondered
if there was something she was supposed to
have done to the boiler after her return.
But the boiler was Mark's domain, and she
did not want to ask him about it. She did
not want to ask him about anything. She did
not want her reverie that he did not exist
and that therefore nothing had happened between
them broken. Besides, she was hardly at home
so it hardly mattered that she was cold. Once
again, this year the application had jumped
up 800 this time, more evidence of the still
swelling population bubble of teenagers. And
too, perhaps, that their efforts to reach
beyond the traditional applicant pool, to
students who might not have thought to apply
ten or even five yeas earlier were proving
successful. It all seemed utterly overwhelming
just now with every surface in her office
piled with files and boxes more waiting downstairs
in the office. But no one was panicking, because
they always felt this way at this particular
moment in the cycle. There had never in Portia's
recollection been any real worry that they
wouldn't finish in time, though the task did
have a way of expanding to fill every worker's
every available hour. This was the point in
the admission cycle when Portia became reacquainted
with many of the students she had spent the
previous spring encouraging to apply to Princeton.
Selling the university, of course, was not
difficult, but overselling it to potential
applicants sat near the top of every critic's
list of complaints. The gist of this being
the top tier colleges went out of their way
to get vast numbers to apply only to admit
an ever smaller percentage and earn, as a
result, a higher US News and World Report
ranking. But while Portia did sometimes wish
that there was a way to selectively discourage
the students she met while visiting high schools,
she would never and could never do it. Not
only was it the office's pop philosophy that
every student should feel welcome to submit
an application, and that equal and thorough
consideration awaited everyone who did so,
the fact was that you just couldn't tell when
you looked into their serious, tremulous faces
at the information sessions who was the kid
who cheated his way through Calculus BC, and
who was the kid whose English teacher was
going to call him the most exciting student
I've had in my 30-year career. What if she
discouraged some student who couldn't break
1200 on his SATs from applying when he would
turn out to be idiosyncratically cerebral?
A true, original kid whose unqualifiedable
abilities would lift the discourse in every
class he enrolled in. How could you know that
the thoroughly dull high school junior struggling
to make conversation over cider and cookies
would emerge as the writing program's most
gifted novelist in a decade? Still, when their
faces came back to her now, swimming up from
the accounts of debating triumphs and stage
fright at the piano recital, she sometimes
wish she have been able to say to them, "Don't.
Don't try for this. Don't want this. Or worse,
make some terrible connection between who
you are as a human being and whether or not
you get in." The pool once again was absurdly
strong. The applicants more driven, more packaged,
more worried even than the year before. They
were decent kids who would never consider
that their life experience wasn't all unusual
since they were like everyone else they knew.
So when they set foot outside the United States
on a church home-building trip to Mexico,
or a visit to relatives in Bombay, they were
stunned by the poverty; dumbstruck to discover
how wealthy and privileged they were. They
wanted to fix things, cure diseases, make
it better. They want to turn into the amazing
people their teachers swore they were, and
their parents had always planned for them
to be. They wanted not to fall short at this
finish line of their entire lives and be that
kid who thought he was so great, could aim
so far above himself. Portia feel for them,
of course. She wish as she checked again and
again the box reading "only if room," a euphemism
for no, as there was never any room. But she
could reach through the folder to the kid
beyond and say, "Anyone would be ecstatic
to have their child turn out as great as you.
And please, go and do all the things you say
you intend to do." Few of them were eliminated
easily. The campaigners who fashioned elaborate
dossiers with glossy 8X10s of their grinning
faces, and sent in reams of thick stock pages
enumerating each spelling tests and charity
works as far back to middle school, could
not be dismissed out of hand, because you
couldn't hold somebody's personality against
them. And besides, some idiot might have told
them to do it. The student who provided an
18th century family tree with a name of a
distant ancestor circled in red could not
be eliminated instantly, though his cover
letter said he wanted to go to Princeton because
his antecedent had helped set up the place.
The girl who had entered her email address
as "HotSexygirl69@yahoo.com" could not be
declined on the spot because even Princeton
applicants were allowed to be idiotic teenagers.
The ones with low SAT scores couldn't be dispatched
quickly because some of them were superb and
thoughtful writers with (inaudible) courtesy
passed the numbers to the singular (inaudible).
So when she came to an applicant who have
given the benefit of every doubt fell decisively
short, she was relieved. Here was one she
did not have to bring to committee, sell to
her colleagues, sell to Clarence. The math
geeks who hadn't done any math outside of
school, only if room. The literary types who
were poor writers, only if room. The faux
philosophers high on Nietzsche and Ayn Rand
who hoped only to find professors worthy of
having them as a student, she had no need
to travel David with their essays. Such as,
"As Sartre wrote in his play 'No exit,' hell
is other people. This play illustrates the
theory of existentialism which is a philosophy
that since God is dead we are all ultimately
responsible for everything that happens to
us. This philosophy is valid in my opinion.
When I first read Sartre's play, I realized
that other people are cowards who hide behind
religion and rules and laws. They think that
their lives are not really up to them, and
this makes them lazy and complacent. Since
the night I've been reading the great works
of philosophy on my own starting with the
Apology of Socrates which shows that it is
important to stand up for what you believe
in even if everyone else thinks you're wrong.
After one year of intense study, I began to
think of my own philosophy. I call it Meta-existentialism,
and it builds on the profound insights as
Socrates and Sartre. My first book, Dionysus
Novus: a Treatise on Agony and Ecstasy is
almost complete.' And I hope they publish
it soon. It argues that we are most real when
we experience intense emotions and that those
who are not capable of intense emotions live
lives that are mediocre and sad. In college,
I hope to develop these ideas and possibly
teach courses in philosophy and literature
to impart my philosophy to others. I have
found that other people often find it hard
to understand my theories, but they are not
professional philosophers, so that is to be
expected. I look forward to study with important
professors who will definitely understand
what I am saying--only if room. The Fannie
Lou Hamer essay had not turned up in the database
but Portia, reading through it again could
not let go of her suspicions. Misspelling
both the title and author of your favorite
book, as this Rhode Island girl had done,
was pretty close to unforgivable on a college
application. But it was the disparity between
this carelessness and superbly fluid well-constructed
and correctly spelled essay that bothered
her. There was little else noteworthy in the
application. The girl was a strong student
who had taken summer classes at Brown, played
squash. She did like the fact that the girl
had written about Hamer, not a more obvious
civil rights figure. That counted for something.
But in the end she could not disentangle herself
from that Pride and Privilege--only if room.
And there would be no room. The National Judo
champion did not appear anywhere on the website
of the United States Judo Federation. Portia
looked through the application again and found
nothing to outweigh this information should
be marked the "unlikely box" effectively concluding
the matter. Which left the application with
the unchecked disciplinary waiver. It was
3:30 in the afternoon when she picked up the
phone, summoning what she could recall of
the counselor from their meeting last May--no
April, on a swing through Boston. Noble and
Greenough, Milton Academy, a charter school
in Roxbirys run by a heroic woman in her 60s,
and Ford Country Day School, Portia's final
stop. The counselor was in her late 30s, small
with blonde hair, blonde streak, and an accent,
Portia remembered thinking more New York than
Boston. Her name right on the secondary school
report was Elisa Rosen. She picked up quickly
as if she's been waiting by the phone. And
if she sounded initially distracted, the utterance
of the word "Princeton," and she snapped to
attention. "Of course, I remember," she said
with great warmth. "You had a name from Shakespeare.
Juliet? Helena?" "Portia." "Oh, yes, the Quality
of Mercy, very appropriate for an admissions
officer." Portia nodded. It was not the first
time she had heard this. "How can I help,"
says Elisa Rosen. "Oh, I just had a quick
question about one of your seniors." "You
got about 20 from us this year." "Yes. His
name is Sean Erinson. I wanted..." "Ah," the
warmth in her voice had fled quite suddenly.
"And what about?" "This may have been nothing,"
she said carefully. "I noticed that the disciplinary
action question wasn't checked. It's not a
huge deal." She listened into the silence
which grew. "Unless..." Portia had said frowning,
"...it is." More silence. "Miss Rosen?" "Elisa,
please," the woman said, "I'm thinking about
this." Portia now thoroughly alert sat waiting,
the application open before her, reading and
rereading the question and question as if
she did not know it by heart. "You know,"
Elisa said abruptly, "I think... Do you mind
terribly if I phone you back in a few minutes?
I'd like to phone you back." "All right,"
said Portia, giving her the direct line. She
hung up the phone and opened the application
to the first page. Dad, an ophthalmologist,
went to Brandeis; mom, a homemaker, went to
Wheaton; two sibs, both older, one in college,
one in medical school; swimming, lots of swimming;
tennis. Probable major: economics; possible
career plans, well, summers tennis pro, working
for dad, calculus and history at Andover.
One essay about his swim coach; one about
tutoring a neighbor's child who have trouble
with Math. His favorite movie was Donnie Darko,
the single, most cited film in this year's
key detail section, trailed only slightly
and incredibly enough by the Princess Bride.
She'd have the impression that Donnie Darko
was a horror film until some boy from Maine
wrote an essay about why he loved it. Now
she concluded it was merely bizarre. The phone
rang, and Portia noted the caller ID on her
phone which was not surprisingly the school
she had just phoned but 617, the right area
code. Tentatively, she answered, "Portia Nathan?
It's Elisa Rosen." "Oh, yes. Hello, Elisa."
"I'm sorry I couldn't talk. I wanted to have
this conversation on my cell," she laughed
shortly, "I'm actually in my car right now."
By this time, Portia was paying very close
attention. "I take that there is an issue
here?" "Oh, yes. And I decided that if any
of you ever asked, I was going to answer.
You're the first one to call, by the way.
Congratulations," she said with deep sarcasm.
Portia found a piece of note paper on her
desk and wrote the name of the counselor and
the date. "I must ask you please to make this
an off-the-record conversation. Can you agree
to that?" Portia considered. "Sean Erinson
had an academic rating of 2 and a non-ac,
3," smack in the middle of the pool. He wasn't
a legacy which vastly decreased the likelihood
of a belligerent phone call if he was rejected.
She could probably terminate the application
without consulting Clarence. "Well, let's
do this. Let's have a conversation. And if
we come into something I think my boss needs
to hear about, I'll stop you and you can think
about it, okay?" "Yes," she said after a minute.
"So what are we talking about here?" "He got
hold of the chemistry final in December. We
have no idea how. His teacher has no idea
how. Apparently, he sold it to at least two
of his classmates, but we can't compel him
to tell us who they are, which hasn't done
wonders for our morale. Plus, when I first
met with him before Christmas, he very clearly
implied that he done it before. He wanted
us to know he'd been having his way with the
system for a while." Portia, listening, turned
over the pages of file for secondary school
transcript, as and A-s with appropriately
enough a single B+ in Foundations of Ethics,
junior year. "So he was suspended then?" "Well,
that's just it. His father told us that if
we suspended him or did anything to the transcript
or the recommendations, he'd sue the school.
He also told our headmaster he was prepared
to claim the chemistry teacher had given Sean
the answers as part of an attempt at deduction.
And he was ready to make a sexual harassment
charge. And the chemistry teacher does happen
to be gay which didn't help. So we were in
meetings for days with our attorney, and finally
felt we just had to let it go. We had to,"
she said defensively. "We didn't want to.
I mean, what I've told you, it doesn't even
scratch the surface of how truly gruesome
it was. And both of his references had already
sent out their letters including, I should
point out, the chemistry teacher who had written
him this glowing recommendation in November.
It would have meant contacting 11 colleges
with whom we've had good relationships and
telling them we had a cheating scandal. But
you know what? When the time came for me to
fill out the SSR, I just couldn't bring myself
to check that box, you know. I couldn't do
it. It's my silent protest." "I see," said
Portia, writing quickly. "Well, thank you
for your candor." "I'm in my car," Elisa Rosen
said again. "I feel like I'm in a spy novel,
but I didn't want anyone to hear me talking
about this. We kept the students from finding
out. I don't know how, but if we hadn't we
would have been overwhelmed with parents demanding
we throw him out and inform the colleges.
They don't want Sean taking their kid's place.
And I have to tell you, I don't really blame
them. But do you know what I hate most about
this whole thing?" "What?" Portia asked. "I
hate the fact that he's actually a sweet kid.
Seriously, I've known Sean for years. You
couldn't meet a nicer guy. Always smiling,
always wants to tell you about some book he's
just read or something that he saw on the
paper. He's very popular but he's one of these
popular kids who reach out to the misfits.
Do you know what I mean? And I'm not excusing
what he did at all, but I got to tell you,
I don't think I'd last a week with a father
like that. I mean, angry, angry man. You could
hear him screaming at his son outside in the
parking lot after our meeting. I wanted to
call child protective services." "Okay," said
Portia, frowning. "So I'm just telling you,
this is what happened. And I have no idea
what he'll be like when he gets away from
home. I mean, Sean is really smart, really
capable. He can absolutely handle the work
at Princeton, and I'm sure he'd be an asset
to the university. But it's right that you
have the information. Are there any applicants
you'd like to discuss?" she said hopefully.
I'm just going to stop there. Thank you so
much. I do the other thing? And now as promised,
Molly Stevens, your fellow Google employee,
has helped me set up a website for a project
that I'm involved with now. This is something
that did grow out of the Admission novel.
In Admission, every chapter begins with a
little excerpt from an application essay.
Some of them are funny. "I accompanied the
Acapella choir," one of my personal favorites.
Some of them were quite serious. But the potential
for satire is so unignorable. And I have a
friend who has gone through several of his
children applying to college, and at one point
he went to Barnes and Noble to try and find
the book about how to write a college essay.
And he was so overwhelmed by how grim most
of them were, he called me and he said, "What
the world really needs is a book of the worst
college essays." So that's what we're trying
to compile. We are looking for the most imbecilic,
absurd, excessive college essays. We want
people to write them for us, and they're very
hard to write. We've turned down, like a Princeton
University admissions officer, we've turned
down most of the essays that have been submitted
to our website. But I brought a couple of
our best ones to reach you, to give you the
idea of what we're looking for and maybe this
will inspire some of you to try your hand
at this because we need more. And if you have
friends who you think might like this assignment,
please have them look at our website which
is FunniestCollegeEssays.com. WWW.funniestcollegeessays.com.
Okay. Here's one of my favorites. From the
time I was in the Odyssey Program for Gifted
Students in the third grade, I have worn the
baseball, the Harvard baseball cap that my
Uncle Kenneth Breadstine, Harvard '72, a major
in [INDISTINCT] to Harvard bought me. Of course,
being respectful, I never wore my Harvard
cap in class, only in the corridors, on the
street, and everywhere else. If you look at
my photo closely, you'll see the proof because
I have permanent hat head. Thin hair on top
and on the sides, bunches out around my ears.
In ninth grade, I almost won the Regional
High School Science Fair for my study of the
social systems of ants, but someone jiggled
the table and my jar of ants crashed to the
floor and the other competitor stepped on
them. In 10th grade Honors History, my teacher
told me that I could have won the Historical
Society Award for the colonial newspaper that
I wrote, but the glue I used to put the newspaper
together made the pages bleed into one another.
If I had done that immediately, I never would
have handed it in that way. Unfortunately,
it waited until I had handed it in to bleed.
And last year, I was absolutely sure that
I was going to win the Junior Class Thespian
Award for my portrayal of the wandering minstrel
Nanki Poo until the costume mistress who has
always behaved toward me in an antagonistic
manner for some reason she had never inform
me of, switched my wooden sandals with those
of Coco, the lord high executioner. And as
a result, I slipped off the stage while wandering.
Also this past summer, I could have gone to
Yugoslavia with my soccer team, but I didn't
want to do anything to harm my straight A-average.
So I went to summer school while everyone
else was hanging out in the mall and taking
who-knows-what drugs. My favorite book is
"Catcher in the Rye" because I identify with
Holden Caulfield who was in therapy like me,
but I would never go to a prostitute like
he did. Also, I'm an extremely moral person
who only wants to use my many talents and
strong work ethic to give back to my community.
For example, the summer before my junior year,
I went to the Mitsba Corps at Rutgers University.
We had choices. We could work in a soup kitchen
or be a counselor in an inner-city camp or
in a camp for adults with disabilities or
with senior citizens. I chose to do all of
them. They said it couldn't be done, but my
Uncle Kenneth Breadstine, Harvard '72, hired
me a limousine so I could show up in each
place for an hour a day. That's all. I won
the Rotary Club for the photography contest
with my photos, the astonished faces of the
inner city kids and the homeless people when
I showed up in that limousine. When I graduate,
my Uncle Kenneth Breadstine, Harvard '72,
has promised to give me a thousand dollars
toward my future tuition to Harvard, a small
percentage of what he'll give to Harvard when
I'm admitted. I hope that you will accept
me into Harvard. Not only will I be forever
grateful but my Uncle Kenneth Breadstine,
Harvard '72, will be forever grateful, too.
That was written Rachel Jewel Shapiro. She
teaches the writing the personal essay course
at UCLA Extension. And that was one of the
first essays that we accepted. Okay, here's
another one. Here's another one. It's not
titled. It goes like this. My favorite saying
is "No guts, no glory." I can't recall who
said it first but whenever I'm in trouble
or facing a big challenge, I think about this
saying. In life, just like on the playing
field, you always have to bring your A-game.
You have to step up to the plate and give
110% if you really want to turn up the heat
on the competition and take things to the
next level. Sure, some people may say it's
only a game, but this is true for the game
of life just like everything else. The fact
that is that anything worth doing is worth
doing well, and every one of us controls our
own destiny. You just take life one game at
a time, and be the best you can be. That's
all anyone can ask from you. I know what it's
like when it's crunch time and our backs are
against the wall. Those were the times when
you have to circle the wagons. There may have
been occasions when my team is in the dumps
because things are going south, but we never
say die. The beat is a bitter pill to swallow,
but sometimes it's just isn't our day. Nobody
ever promised us a rose garden. The game may
not be cakewalk but to me, a tough competitor
is a wake up call. Even if the game is a nail
biter, there's nothing like snatching victory
from the jaws of defeat. The crowd goes wild
and it's time to rewrite the record books.
My teammates are like my family, and every
game is a team effort. No one ask for personal
glory and no one gets it. After all, there's
no "I" in team. The days we experience the
thrill of victory are the days that make you
want to get out of bed in the morning, but
no one knows what that day will bring. I truly
believe that everything happens for a reason,
and life never shuts the door without opening
a window. In trying times such as this, you
can't do better than live by the golden rule.
If everyone did, the world would be a better
place. So once again, that's www.funniestcollegeessays.com.
I hope you will all have a look at it. And
please, send us essays because we really want
them. Yeah?
>> FEMALE: I have some friends that I think
might be able to contribute.
>> KORELITZ: Excellent.
>> FEMALE: So I'll certainly pass that along.
I'm curious about your introductory comment
that I very much agree with some of the things
you said in terms of that somewhat negative
light that a lot of the youth in this country
has been portrayed, and I personally have
a number of very close [INDISTINCT] in Princeton
so this is quite comical for me. But--and
I agree that while wonderful, many of them
are very normal. My brother probably wouldn't
appreciate that. In any case, I'm wondering--you
see an older sibling and relative, I do see
incredible talent and interest in improving
the world. But I'm wondering what your perspective
both from your involvement with the university
and then, you know, as a writer and as a parent.
It seems to me to some degree that whether
it's the application process or the packaging
that you mentioned that there's so much pressure
and there's this innocence lost that I feel.
And so I'm just wondering your perspective
on that.
>> KORELITZ: I think it's one of so many ironies
of the process that it takes place at this
point in the development of young people,
because young people aren't idiots. I mean,
they're imbeciles. Teenagers behave like complete
imbeciles but here's the point. Don't we want
them to? Would we rather that that phase of
behaving irrationally, you know, comes in
the 30s or the 40s? No. This is when we want
them to behave badly. This is when we want
them to make mistakes. This is when we want
them to take these detours that, you know,
sometimes the only information that can be
gleaned from the detour is I don't want to
do that anymore. I don't want to be that kind
of person that I just spent the last half
year being. And yet, you know, we now have
this microscope over these couple of years,
and it's a great, great shame. And one of
the first things that we were taught in our
training is, the process does not favor the
late bloomer. But look at late bloomers among
us who have enriched all of our lives. And
it's very sad and I think the people who make
these decisions are very aware of it, but
what can they do? You know, they're not fortune
tellers. You don't get a crystal ball. You
know, it's very sad. But, you know, the late
bloomers bloom eventually and then they can
become professors at Princeton. I mean, I
would just say this about my husband. My husband
barely graduated from college, and now he's
a Princeton professor. And you know, there's
a reason for that. But you know, sometimes
in the fullness of time, these talents flower.
So, I hope that answered your question. Is
there any other question? Okay. Thank you
so much for having me. It was really a pleasure.
>> STEVENS: Thank you.